c'est un moment historique qui redessine
la carte de la sécurité en Europe
en rejoignant l'OTAN la Finlande tourne
la page de sa politique de
non-alignement militaire en vigueur
depuis les années 90
première conséquence la frontière de
l'OTAN remonte vers le Nord à la
frontière avec la Russie et sa longe de
1300 km
l'intégration de la Finlande élargit la
sphère d'influence de l'OTAN vers
l'article région stratégique en raison
de ses ressources naturelles et de son
emplacement
je pense que les Américains les Français
et les Britanniques y voit leur intérêt
d'un point de vue géostratégique la
défense de l'Europe du Nord devient
beaucoup plus facile
autre intérêt pour l'Alliance la
puissance militaire finlandaise la
plupart des hommes dans le pays font
leur service militaire d'après les
statistiques officielles les troupes
quant à ce jour 280 000 soldats et 900
000 réservistes ce qui en fait l'une des
plus grandes armées de l'Alliance ces
forces participent déjà aux exercices
militaires conjoints avec l'OTAN ils
sont experts pour les opérations en
climat extrême
la Finlande dispose d'autres Expertis
techniques utiles aux Alliés depuis des
décennies toutes les strates de la
société se préparent à l'éventualité
d'un conflit avec le voisin russe
Helsinki stockent l'équivalent de 6 mois
d'approvisionnement en carburant et de
nombreux bâtiments disposent d'abris
Antibes